[Music]
foreign you are watching The Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive in the next
half hour we'll see what's making the
headlines where the journalist and
author Christina Patterson and editor of
the Jewish Chronicle Jake Wallace Simons
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now the Sunday
Telegraph has the latest from Matt
Hancock's leaked WhatsApp messages with
claims he wanted to ramp up a new
variant to scare people
The Observer leads with a senior Tory
MPS turning on Boris Johnson saying his
response to the most recent party gate
report shows he has gone full Trump
the Sunday Times claims thousands of
Ukrainian children have been abducted
and taken to Russian re-education camps
as the war continues
the mirror goes with Prince Harry's
latest interview where he says he and
other members of the royal family don't
speak the same language
the Duke of Sussex is revealing live
streamed chat is also on the front of
the Sunday people which refers to him as
deluded
the mail on Sunday says prime minister
Rishi sunak is set to introduce new laws
this week to put an end to migrants
crossing the English Channel in small
boats
the express is also leading on the PM's
vow to slow down the number of people
seeking asylum in the UK
and according to doctors getting a
six-pack might not be as good for you as
you may think that's on the front of the
star
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Christina Patterson and Jake Wallace
Simons welcome to both of you let's
start with the Telegraph and further
revelations in the lockdown the
so-called lockdown files from the Sunday
Telegraph fill us in on the latest
Christina
well goodness to me this one is clearly
going to run and run and I I personally
think Isabel oakshot has behaved
dishonorably and I think clearly a lot
of this stuff would have emerged because
it was all handed to the investigation
and it would have and will emerge when
the investigation is uh you know takes
place and we can all read the report
though it's true that is likely to be
some time ahead but I think the main for
me the main message that comes across
from these WhatsApp messages is just
that they are an incredibly unedifying
spectacle I think the way that people
members of the government spoke about
all kinds of people the public primarily
but also senior scientists like sir
Jeremy Farrah
um people like the head of the NHS Sir
Simon Stevens uh they just spoke with
such contempt often using foul language
and it I I just find it quite setting
the fact that Matt Hancock was talking
about scaring the pants of the public by
using the talk of a new variant as a
kind of com strategy I mean we were all
ready very scared and rightly right so
because under this government's handling
of covid
tens of thousands of people died and
many of them are necessarily not least
because Matt Hancock's claimed to be
putting a protective ring around Care
Homes turned out to be a total lie so I
I find the whole thing quite upsetting
and the telegraph is using these
messages for its own agenda which is
that it was always fiercely opposed to
lockdown and it's apparently showing
that um you know that lockdown was
imposed for bad reasons or in bad faith
or for political reasons and they do
seem to be elements of that there but
they don't see what the alternative
would have been and the alternative
would have been many more people dying
and the NHS collapsing because let's not
think that this was about Boris Johnson
having a lovely warm heart to the
British public this was about making
sure that the NHS didn't actually
collapse in a visible way it did
collapse actually in all kinds of ways
but the pr disaster of the NHS being
seen to collapse would have been
something that no government could
survive so overall extremely unedifying
and rather upsetting
um what what do you think Jake when when
you read that the quote sort of revealed
in these WhatsApp messages
um Mr Hancock saying in one we frighten
the pants off everyone with the new
strain and the response is yep that's
what we'll get proper behavior
change yes Behavior change what do you
think when you you read those quotes
well frankly I I feel that Matt Hancock
has got to be probably one of the most
repellent people in public life at the
moment uh you know day after day these
Revelations of how he behaved during
that terrifying period for everybody
um of great distress
um seeing in his own words how he was
preoccupied with his own self-image how
he was obsessed with pushing forward
um quite extreme lockdown policies even
in the face of evidence that led to
other conclusions
um the way in which he behaved with this
sort of venal self-serving Macho
ideological approach I think really is
is beneath contempt and this latest
Revelation that he wanted to frighten
the pants off people in order to get
them to comply with a heavily handed
government dictat rather than give them
the evidence and the respect to to make
their own decisions about risk and how
they would best behave
um I think is absolutely appalling
um the government consistently
um exaggerated the threat we knew this
exaggerated the threat uh exaggerated
the figures in some cases nudged people
um and tried to frighten the pants off
people now we we find out
um in order to get people to comply
through Terror uh to measures that were
overly Draconian taking individual
responsibility out of the picture
entirely I mean this is not Behavior
which befits any kind of of Tori let
alone
um anyone in in a democracy and I think
that really the the revelations day
after day get more and more egregious
and there were accusations at the time
weren't there of the the government
scaremongering
um and we now see that's exactly what
they were doing let's move on to the
Observer and um party gate yes it's
still with us another day I know you you
realize that we would be talking about
it again this quote on the front of the
Observer he's gone for Donald Trump
suggesting that even conservatives uh
turning against the former prime
minister Boris Johnson in terms of the
party gate
Christina
yes well he he I mean I think that's a
pretty accurate assessment of the
situation and let's not forget that this
was the context all of that scaring the
pants of the public very often with
Boris Johnson's well clearly with Boris
Johnson's approval and endorsement
although what's also clear from the
WhatsApp messages is that he changed his
mind every few minutes according to the
latest person he spoke to so Dominic
Cummings assessment of him as a shopping
trolley seems to have been entirely
accurate but the report from MPS which
has been uh released yesterday was
released yesterday is extremely damning
and indicates that it looks as though on
at least four occasions Boris Johnson
did mislead Parliament and when you see
again the what's that messages behind
the scenes which Show members of staff
at Downing Street
essentially unable to come up with any
justification and saying things like you
know hard to find a reason for this in
my head or
um trying to remember some of the others
now but extremely damning and and one
said something like well this one sounds
like a piss up and you know to be honest
that's that seems like pretty fair I
mean I'm paraphrasing but that's that's
what the what's that one of the WhatsApp
messages said so it's a very very
damning assessment and looks quite
likely to see Boris Johnson band from
Parliament for at least 10 days could be
longer and which could well lead to a
by-election and for him to instantly say
that this report vindicates him it's and
it is champion because it's a total
contradiction of what the report
actually says so I mean I'll just be
delighted when he sculpts off from
public life I think I think support for
him is draining both in the Tory party
and clearly already has in the country
and I think that raising party gate
again will not help him in any way at
all because I think that is the one
thing the public will never ever ever
forgive him for Tobias Elwood quoted uh
the chair of the defense select
committee saying that the Prime Minister
wishes soon act had shown real
leadership with last week's deal on the
Northern Ireland protocol but warned
that the progress risk being undermined
by Johnson uh in a reference to the
xpm's behavior I would add it if we now
stay United and disciplined we could win
the general election but not if this
latest distraction turns into a trumpian
drag anchor do you think it is enough of
a distraction to undermine the
conservative party
Jake
I think that I think that um if the Tory
party doesn't manage to unite and find
some kind of common
reality then winning the next election
would be very difficult indeed at the
same time I have some sympathy for Boris
Johnson because this inquiry really has
appeared quite biased from the start and
the people involved in the inquiry from
Harriet Harmon downwards have almost all
of them expressed uh opposition to
dislike of Boris Johnson many times in
the past there were four conservatives
there were full conservatives amongst
the the MPS weren't there
that's right for conservatives and only
one of them has not criticized Boris
Johnson in the past all the others have
and attacked him and tried to undermine
him in different ways including being
part of the attempt to topple him
through resignations the problem is that
Boris Johnson is a lightning rod for uh
for for the brexit issue the divisive
brexit issue and whether you're a Tory
or a lib Dem or an SMP member there's
one SMP member on the panel as well and
if you are pro-remain uh you will have a
level of hatred for Boris Johnson it
looks like a lot of them are motivated
about that and let's not forget that
this report that's been released uh is a
sort of pre-judgment it's a pre-report
Boris himself hasn't yet had a chance to
put his views across which is going to
happen I think next week and so this
this report says that there's some
suggestion that he's misled Parliament
but it's inconclusive
um and it's so odd to release a report
before even having the evidence from the
man concerned and so it does appear as
if mine's already made up and about how
Boris Johnson has has behaved it does
have a faint whiff of a kangaroo court
as a Daily Mail has put it today
as the Daily Mail would
um let's move on to the current prime
minister at Rishi sunec and um new
policy in regards of one of his pledges
to stop the small boats uh coming
um across the channel this sounds quite
um quite severe
Christina
yeah it sounds pretty Draconian and I
think Rishi sunak apparently he's
devoting more attention to this than
anything except the economy because he
knows it's a lightning issue for voters
and particularly red wall voters and he
everyone every Tory prime minister and
Home Secretary has been vowing to stop
the votes for a long time and he's the
latest I mean it sounds extremely
Draconian to me but I also have to say
that I think the current system
absolutely isn't working because we have
a system of
quasi-immigration and Asylum seeking
which is essentially enabling enabled by
people's Smugglers and gives
um privileged access to young men who
are able to pay people's Smugglers so it
doesn't give a look in for very many
women or children and it's people who
can play the system so the whole and of
course people do risk their lives they
do die and if they do get here they are
housed at considerable expense by the
British taxpayer you know I am certainly
not anti-immigration I live in Hackney
which is one of the most diverse
boroughs in the UK and you know I'm
extremely in favor of a mixed and
Multicultural Society however the system
as it currently operates which is you
know as I say basically enabled by
criminals is not serving the UK and it's
not serving the people who are risking
their lives in the process so someone
has to come up with a better solution
I'm not convinced that this is it but
Jake this will mean that that anyone who
who comes here on a small boat illegally
will not ever be able to to claim Asylum
there'll be uh sent to either Rwanda or
another safe country so they will not be
able to claim Asylum
yes that's right I think it's important
to be clear about this this is not an
anti-immigration measure as such
immigration is higher now than it was in
2016 when we voted to leave the EU and
it's not an anti-asylum measure either
people still are able to claim asylum in
Britain and what it is is a measure to
stop the small boats which as Christine
has mentioned pump money into the people
smuggling networks
um privileged young men who have have
enough money to pay them
um and in the end take people who are
escaping not from war-sorn countries but
from France from where they they come
over to Britain in in small boats
risking their lives and and wasting a
lot of uh resources and heartache in
trying to rescue them and causing a
ripple effect of other problems uh and
so I think that the government's
proposal to not allow any Asylum to be
granted to people who come from France
in dinghies to Britain is probably the
only way to counter this and I speak
someone who's reported quite a lot on
the migrant Trail as it was called over
the years has met many of these people
from all the way from
um from Macedonia through to Greece and
Canaan all the rest of it and some of
them have heartbreaking stories others
are on the bandwagon to try to exploit
the um the the trauma of refugees but
either way once they reach France they
are safe and for them to then risk their
lives further to come over the channel
and in some cases lose their lives I
think it's an appalling State of Affairs
and the government's right to to propose
this sort of legislation yeah certainly
one of his uh top five policy priorities
and the male also covering that story
um quoting which you soon make no
mistake I'll Deport Channel migrants
Christine and Jake for the moment thank
you we are going to take a break coming
up reaction to Prince Harry's live chat
including this on the front of the
mirror their headline Harry's new blast
at Charles
stay with us
[Music]
foreign
still with me journalist and author
Christina Patterson and the editor of
the Jewish Chronicle Jake Wallace Simons
welcome back to both of you let us have
a look at the mirror and don't groan
um Prince Harry is uh back in the
newspapers he's given this um uh
interview sort of a kind of
counseling session that he's undertaken
and some new Revelations newest
Revelations have come out of that
Christina
yeah I mean can't we send him off to
Rwanda without any Wi-Fi or Spotify or
any of the other things that are making
him an absolute Fortune I mean
it's got to the point where it's just
embarrassing actually the fact that this
man is making hundreds of millions out
of selling his sub story which if you
look at the rest of the news today
what's happening in Ukraine what's
happening with Ukrainian children what's
happening with people struggling to pay
their bills in this country
I find it breathtaking that one man can
think that his own apparent trauma can
be so incredibly fascinating and
newsworthy and worthy of the attention I
do feel sorry for what Harry has been
through you know he he does he his
latest claim is he came from a broken
home like about 50 of children now so it
doesn't exactly put him in a kind of
extremely rarefied
um a group but and of course what he
experienced in terms of media intrusion
particularly as a child and the death of
his mother was devastating but it was
not the worst suffering in the whole
world and the fact that he has the
hutzpah actually to go to to sort of do
these highly monetized
podcasts films interviews claiming
talking about his trauma it's
breathtaking and it's breathtakingly
unkind to his family Charles must just
be I mean Charles came across as a very
loving father in all the stuff that has
emerged so far in the book in the
Netflix and so on constantly calling him
my darling boy and you know being very
affectionate and now he's moaning about
not having had enough hugs as a child
lack of love I think I mean I could I'm
sort of being completely in articulate
when I talk about him because I find it
breathtaking and really upsetting that
anyone can go on and on and on about
their pain so much I just wish someone
would pay him to shut up quite frankly
Jake do you have any sympathy for Prince
Harry I mean he is certainly feeling
this this trauma it's real
I think it will be inhuman to say that
one didn't feel any sympathy for Prince
Harry at all I mean obviously he's had a
very strange and difficult life anyway
as a royal in growing up in the public
eye plus the death of his mother and all
the things that we know about must have
contributed towards a sense of trauma or
difficulty
um but it's very hard to have any
sympathy for how he's behaving as a
result of it at the moment in
continually slinging hand grenades from
his verified La Mansion into Windsor uh
Castle or Buckingham Palace and really
doing a lot of damage to an institution
that means so much to so many people and
this latest episode this sort of live
counseling session with Gabor mate I
think really is very revealing of his of
his uh milia and his sense of judgment
because Gabriel mate as the Jewish
Chronicle actually has reported this
week is a very problematic a
controversial figure supporter of Jeremy
Corbin who has defended Hamas terrorists
and indeed has compared them to the
Jewish fighters who fought the Nazis uh
in the second world war and so this is a
very controversial and outspoken hard
left figure that Prince Harry is
associating with spilling his uh heart
to in public on television I mean it's
very very unedifying and insulting to a
lot of people so as much sympathy as we
have for him and what he's been through
as a child is very difficult to condone
the way in which he's behaving now as an
adult Christina these Sunday people the
headline um quoting Harry is saying
showing my trauma is an act of of
service your thoughts on that
well the the Sunday people with which I
don't very often um agree uh is calling
him deluded and I I'm afraid I think
that is exactly right the idea that the
greatest act of service he can uh
contribute to the world now is talking
about his trauma I mean how about
actively volunteering how about giving
some of those Millions to help
um people who really are suffering we I
think we've seen from the archwell
accounts that very little has actually
been given to charity and he and his
wife are raking it in they are really
raking it in so I'm afraid I think he is
deluded and I think the people who are
advising him are advising him very badly
I don't doubt that all of this
extraordinary behavior is the result of
something but it's shocking Christina
we've run out of time must leave it
there thank you so much